but our question tonight on the angle is
how much longer can he avoid answering
questions and is he putting off his 2024
announcement because of this joining us
now Charlie hurt opinion editor at the
Washington times at a Fox News
contributor in our reflect your former
White House Press Secretary and also a
Fox News contributor Ari you've been in
the cauldron in the white house when the
Press wants answers did it seem like
Biden
um felt comfortable in that situation he
gave that kind of odd smile a lot of
people noticed it what was going through
your mind when you saw that
well I think there's two types of not
talking from the president one is you
you don't talk because it's political
because there's something military going
on so you just don't want to talk the
other though is you're ordered by your
lawyers or you're told by your lawyers
that if you talk you could be exposing
yourself to criminal liability anybody
you talk to could become a witness that
the independent Council special counsel
can call and say what exactly did Joe
Biden say to you that applies to White
House staff every time the White House
Press Secretary talks to the White House
counsel she could get questioned Now by
that independent special counsel so
that's why they clam up but the Press
should not let them get away with it I
understand what the White House has to
do but their ways the Press can bang at
the White House especially the president
to try to get more answers now Charlie
it seemed like Biden
was poised to announce his 2024
um re-election bid early in the new year
is this kind of delaying all that can he
delay it long into the new year oh I
think I I I in fact I think that uh part
of the reason a lot of this is coming
out right now is because everybody felt
fairly certain he was going to announce
uh in short order and I think that you
know look if you just step back and you
look at what we now know the Department
of Justice did during the 2020 campaign
to cover problems for Joe Biden and to
uh to help get him elected and what the
Press obviously did to cover for Joe
Biden they're not doing that anymore to
me that's the biggest takeaway from all
of this the press and the doj have both
at some level turned on on Joe Biden and
Joe Biden can't win anything unless he's
got the doj and the Press working for
him well Ari this goes to your expertise
in this matter I mean the Press really
did protect Biden all through the 2020
campaign they allowed him to do that
hologram campaign where he never really
had to appear never really had to answer
questions
that's turned has it not
yeah you know it turned for the first
time after the failed withdrawal from
Afghanistan and then they went kind of
quiet and easy on Biden again but now
the heat is turned up again this happens
when justice department announces a
special counsel is investigating the
president but if I was the White House
Press Corps here's what I would do Laura
instead of asking questions where you
know they won't answer ask process
questions ask the press secretary when
you said that the search was complete
and it wasn't who told you that
was that the White House counsel or ask
the press secretary have you been in
touch with Joe Biden's personal attorney
is that where you get your information
from you can unravel a lot about what's
going on in the white house if you would
ask process questions that she should
answer she doesn't have to clam up about
those same with the Wester the White
House staff these are things that press
Corps should be digging to into
and it's going to expose how the White
House blundered so badly in telling the
American people what was found when was
found and when they said it was complete
when it was found again and then one
fourth time again classified documents
found and this is serious Laura because
you cannot have classified documents
outside the White House yeah well
Charlie I mean we we joked last
Wednesday or Thursday before we learned
about the other document that was
documents that were found that the
documents were going to be in the in the
dog's dog bed or they'd be shoved in the
bicycle basket you know you could find
them later on but I mean little did we
know the drip drip drip was real
I don't think a lot of people are
confident that there aren't more
documents out there I mean there's no
reason for us to believe that there
aren't not not at this juncture
no I I wouldn't I I think that the
probably the presumption should be that
there we are going to hear about more
that there are more documents out there
look the bottom line is Joe Biden stole
these documents from the from the Obama
Administration uh they have been we
don't know where they've been for six
years but for some reason the Department
of Justice allowed his lawyers to go in
and process the crimes the crime scene
and uh and and you know we need to get
to the answers to all of these questions
yeah dual justice under Merrick Garland
Charlie and Ari thank you so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else